Je lis tout le temps de la poésie
et j'écris souvent sur ce sujet.
Je démonte les poèmes
pour voir comment ils fonctionnent
car je suis un homme de mots.
Je comprends mieux le monde, plus entièrement,
en mots, plutôt qu'en images, ou en nombres
et quand j'ai une nouvelle expérience, ou un nouveau sentiment,
je me sens un peu frustré
jusqu'à ce que j'arrive à le mettre en mots.
Je pense que j'ai toujours été comme cela.
Enfant, je dévorais les livres de science-fiction. Je le fais toujours.
Et j'ai découvert des poésies d'Andrew Marvell,
de Matthew Arnold, d'Emily Dickinson
et de William Butler Yeats
car ils étaient cités dans la science-fiction
et que j'adorais leur sons
et, après, j'ai commencé à lire sur les ottava rima,
les césures en milieu de vers et les enjambements,
toutes ces choses techniques
qui sont importantes pour vous si vous aimez vraiment la poésie
car les poèmes m'ont déjà rendu plus heureux,
plus triste et plus vivant.
Je suis devenu critique en poésie car
je voulais savoir comment et pourquoi.
La poésie n'a pas qu'un objectif
tout comme la musique ou la programmation informatique.
Le mot grec pour poème veut uniquement dire « création » ;
la poésie est un ensemble de techniques,
de façons de créer des configurations
pour mettre en mots des émotions.
Plus vous connaissez de techniques,
plus vous pouvez créer de choses,
et plus vous pouvez reconnaître de modèles
dans les choses que vous aimiez peut-être déjà.
Ceci dit, la poésie semble être
particulièrement bonne pour certaines choses.
Par exemple, nous allons tous mourir.
La poésie peut nous aider à vivre avec cela.
Les poèmes ne sont faits de rien d'autre que de mots.
Les effets dans les poèmes sont comme
les particularités, les personnalités
qui permettent de distinguer les gens les uns des autres.
Les poèmes se partagent facilement, se transmettent facilement
et quand on lit un poème, on peut imaginer
quelqu'un nous le raconter,
ou peut-être encore quelqu'un qui est loin,
une personne imaginaire ou quelqu'un de décédé.
C'est pourquoi, on peut se réfugier dans la poésie quand on veut
se remémorer quelque chose,
fêter quelque chose, regarder au delà de la mort,
ou dire au revoir.
Et c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles les poèmes semblent importants,
même pour d'autres personnes que moi,
qui ne vivent pas autant dans un monde fait de mots.
Le poète Franck O'Hara disait :
« Malheur à vous si vous n'avez pas besoin de poésie »,
mais il disait également que quand il ne voulait plus être en vie,
la pensée qu'il n'écrirait plus aucun poème
l'arrêtait.
La poésie m'aide à aimer la vie
et je veux vous montrer pourquoi en vous montrant comment,
comment quelques poèmes réagissent au fait que
nous vivons à un endroit et dans une culture donnés,
et que dans d'autre circonstances, nous ne serions pas vivants du tout.
Donc voici un des premiers poèmes que j'ai mémorisés.
Il pourrait être adressé à un enfant ou un adulte.
« Depuis loin, depuis la veille et matin
Depuis ce ciel aux douze vents
Les choses de la vie pour me lier
Ici ont soufflé ; me voici.
Maintenant -- je m'attarde pour un souffle
Ne te disperse pas encore --
Prends vite ma main et dis-moi
Ce que tu as dans le cœur.
Parle maintenant, et je répondrai ;
Comment puis-je t'aider, dis ;
Avant les douze quartiers du vent
Je marche mon chemin infini. »
[A. E. Housman]
Ce poème a inspiré
des écrivains de science-fiction.
Il a fourni au moins trois titres de science-fiction,
je pense que la raison en est qu'il dit que les poèmes peuvent nous donner
des nouvelles venant du futur, du passé
ou de l'autre bout du monde,
parce que leurs motifs peuvent sembler vous dire
ce qu'il y a dans le cœur de quelqu'un.
Il dit que les poèmes peuvent temporairement réunir les gens,
ce qui est vrai à mon avis,
et il me reste dans la tête pas simplement parce qu'il rime
mais à cause de la façon dont il rime,
proprement et simplement sur la deuxième et la quatrième
« dis » et « chemin »,
avec des indices en anticipation pour la première et la troisième
« répondrai » et « quartiers »,
comme si le poème se faisait de lui-même.
Il joue de notre mort
en exagérant la vitesse de nos vies.
Plusieurs années sur Terre deviennent
un discours, un souffle.
C'est un poème sur la solitude --
le « je » dans le poème induit qu'aucun lien ne dure --
et cela pourrait ressembler à un appel à l'aide
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive au mot « aide »,
où ce « je » qui vous fait face, qui vous prend la main,
relève plus du professeur ou du génie,
c'est tout du moins ce qu'il veut croire.
Ce ne serait pas la première fois qu'un poète
ait écrit ce qu'il voulait entendre.
Le prochain poème a vraiment changé
ce que j'aime et ce que je lis
et ce que je pensais pouvoir lire en tant qu'adulte.
Cela n'aura peut-être pas de sens pour vous
si vous ne l'avez jamais vu.
« Le Jardin »
« Laurier rose : corail
des publicités de rouge à lèvres dans les années 50.
Fruit de l'arbre de tant de savoir
« Smack (thin air) »
signifie embrasser ou frapper.
Il apparaît
avec l'aspect d'usages désuets
parce que nous sommes mauvais ?
Grosse menace masculine,
pleine de sous-entendus et argotique. »
[Rae Armantrout]
J'ai trouvé ce poème dans une anthologie
de 1989 regroupant des poèmes presque tous aussi déroutants.
J'ai entendu dire qu'ils étaient ces auteurs scandaleux
appelés poètes de la Langue, qui écrivaient n'importe quoi,
et je voulais aller voir de moi-même à quoi ils ressemblaient,
certains d'entre eux ne m'ont pas beaucoup apporté,
mais cette auteure, Rae Armantrout,
m'a beaucoup touché, et j'ai continué à la lire
jusqu'à ce que j'ai l'impression de comprendre ce qu'il se passait,
comme c'est le cas avec ce poème.
Cela parle du Jardin d’Éden, du Déluge
et de l'histoire biblique du Déluge,
dans laquelle le sexe comme nous le connaissons,
la mort et la culpabilité
viennent au monde en même temps.
Cela parle aussi de la déception liée aux apparences,
comment notre culture peut nous entraîner
à faire et dire des choses que nous ne souhaitions pas faire ou dire,
ou que nous n'aimons pas, et le style d'Armantrout
est d'essayer de nous aider à arrêter ou ralentir.
« Smack » peut vouloir dire « embrasser » comme par exemple envoyer des baisers,
ou embrasser sur la bouche,
mais peut aussi signifier « frapper »
comme de la violence domestique,
parce qu'une attirance sexuelle peut paraître menaçante.
Le rouge qui signifie fertilité
peut aussi évoquer du poison.
Le laurier rose est un poison.
Et les usages désuets comme « smack » pour « embrasser »
ou « frapper » peuvent nous aider à voir
comment nos préjugés non reconnus
peuvent nous faire penser que nous sommes mauvais,
soit parce que le sexe est un péché
ou parce que nous tolérons tant de sexisme.
Nous laissons les garçons dire aux femmes ce qu'elles doivent faire.
Le poème réagit à de vieilles publicités pour du rouge à lèvres,
et la phrase ambiguë,
ses revirements et arrêts, ont tout à voir
avec la résistance au langage publicitaire
qui veut si facilement nous dire ce que nous devons vouloir,
faire, penser.
Cette résistance est importante à l'objectif du poème,
ce qui me montre, Armantrout me montre
ce que c'est que d'entendre de graves menaces
et de la malhonnêteté mortelle dans le langage quotidien,
et une fois qu'elle a fait cela,
je pense qu'elle peut montrer aux autres, femmes et hommes,
ce que c'est que de ressentir cela
et de dire aux autres, femmes et hommes,
qui se sentent à ce point aliénés et menacés
qu'ils ne sont pas seuls.
Je ne sais pas si j'ai raison
à propos de ce poème déroutant.
Pour celui-ci, j'ai envoyé un brouillon de mon exposé au poète
et elle a dit : « Oui, oui, il parle de cela. »
Ouais. (Rires) (Applaudissements)
Mais d'habitude, vous ne pouvez pas savoir. Vous ne savez jamais.
Vous ne pouvez pas être certain, et c'est bien ainsi.
Tout ce que nous pouvons faire, c'est écouter des poèmes
lire des poèmes, imaginer
et voir s'ils peuvent nous apporter ce dont nous avons besoin,
et si vous avez tort à propos d'une partie d'un poème,
rien de mauvais n'arrivera.
Le prochain poème est plus vieux que celui d'Armantrout,
mais un peu plus jeune que celui de A. E. Housman.
« L'Homme Courageux »
« Le soleil, cet homme courageux,
Arrive au travers de branches qui gisent en l'attendant,
Cet homme courageux.
Des yeux verts et sombres
dans l'obscurité de l'herbe
S'enfuient.
Les bonnes étoiles,
Pâles gouvernails et éperons pointus,
S'enfuient.
Les peurs de mon lit,
La peur de la vie et la peur de la mort,
S'enfuient.
Cet homme courageux monte
D'en dessous et marche sans méditation,
Cet homme courageux. »
[Wallace Stevens]
Le soleil dans ce poème
de Wallace Stevens semble si grave
parce que la personne dans le poème est si effrayée.
Le soleil se lève le matin au travers de branches,
écarte la rosée, les yeux, dans la pelouse,
et met en défaite les étoiles perçues comme des armées.
« Courageux » a un vieux sens tapageur
et un sens plus moderne, le courage.
Ce soleil n'a pas peur de montrer son visage.
Mais la personne dans le poème a peur.
Il est peut-être resté debout toute la nuit.
C'est la révélation que Stevens garde pour la quatrième strophe,
quand « s'enfuient » est devenu un refrain.
Cette personne pourrait également vouloir s'enfuir,
mais enhardi par l'exemple du soleil,
il pourrait se lever.
Stevens garde ce mot à consonance étrange « méditation »
pour la fin.
Contrairement au soleil, les êtres humains pensent.
Nous réfléchissons au passé et au futur, à la vie et à la mort,
avant et après.
Et cela peut nous effrayer.
Les poèmes, les motifs dans les poèmes,
ne nous montrent pas uniquement ce que quelqu'un pensait,
ce que quelqu'un a fait ou ce qu'il s'est passé,
mais ce que cela faisait d'être quelqu'un comme cela,
d'être si anxieux, si seul, si curieux,
si niais, si absurde, si courageux.
C'est pour cela que les poèmes paraissent à la fois si durables,
si personnels, et si éphémères,
comme quelque chose qui se trouverait à la fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur.
La poète écossaise Denise Riley compare la poésie
à une aiguille, un petit morceau de l'extérieur que je chéris à l'intérieur,
et le poète américain Terrance Hayes
a écrit six poèmes appelés « Du Vent dans une Boîte ».
L'un d'entre eux interroge : « Dis-moi,
que vais-je faire quand je serai mort ? »
Et la réponse est qu'il restera avec nous
ou ne restera pas avec nous comme le vent,
comme l'air, comme les mots.
Il est plus simple que jamais de trouver des poèmes
qui pourraient rester en nous, qui pourraient rester avec nous,
des poèmes d'il y a très très longtemps ou d'il y a une minute,
de très loin ou de très près d'où nous vivons,
peu importe où nous vivons.
Les poèmes peuvent vous aider à montrer, à dire ce que vous ressentez,
mais ils peuvent également vous faire découvrir
les sentiments, les façons d'exister dans le monde,
les gens, vraiment différents de vous,
peut-être même des gens d'un très lointain passé.
Certains poèmes vous disent même
que c'est ce dont ils sont capables.
C'est ce que fait John Keats
dans son poème, peut-être, le plus mystérieux.
C'est mystérieux parce qu'il n'est probablement pas fini,
il ne l'a probablement pas achevé,
et parce qu'il pourrait être prévu
pour un rôle de théâtre,
mais peut-être que Keats pensait simplement
à sa propre écriture,
son écriture manuscrite,
et là-dedans j'entends, j'entends au moins la mortalité,
et j'entends le pouvoir des anciennes techniques de poésie,
et j'ai l'impression, vous l'avez peut-être aussi,
de rencontrer pour un instant, de presque devenir,
quelqu'un d'autre d'un lointain passé,
quelqu'un de mémorable.
« Cette main vivante, maintenant chaude et ayant
une sérieuse poigne, serait, s'il faisait froid
et dans le silence glacé de la tombe,
Tellement hantée ces jours-ci et fraîche ces nuits de rêve
Que vous ne devriez jamais espérer que votre cœur soit sec de sang
Afin que dans mes veines rouges, la vie coule à nouveau,
Et ayez la conscience apaisée -- regardez, le voici --
Je le retiens contre vous. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)